سنواصل التطبيع مع السعوديه بعد انتهاء
الحرب هكذا اعلنتها تلبيب بعد التمديد امل
فرنسي باستمرار الهدنه في ال طاع ما السبب
من الاراضي العبريه ايلون ماسك يتراجع
بشان القطاع مدمره امريكيه تحرر السفينه
المختطفه في اليمن لتستقبلها الصواريخ
البريطانيون يهجمون على مصنع يدعم الكيان
المفوضيه الاوروبيه تصرح من غير المجدي
تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لمن سيقتل غدا
الاداره الامريكيه تلجا الى اجراء من
الحرب البارده كوريا الشماليه تتعهد
باطلاق المزيد من الاقمار الصناعيه خلال
فتره قصيره موسكو تمتلك ادله تدين واشنطن
ماهي الاعلام الامريكي يدق ناقوس الخطر
بسبب مقاتله روسيه استثنائيه والنيتو لقد
حان الوقت لانضمام السويد سريان التمديد
قبل ان تتجدد الهدنه بطلب من معظم دول
العالم ولو لايام قليله على الاقل حتى
يلتقط المدنيون انفاسهم وحتى تحصل الدول
على مطالبها وبعد ان اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
القطريه التوصل الى اتفاق لتمديد الهدنه
الانسانيه في القطاع ليومين اضافيين
لاطلاق المزيد من الاسرى والمحتجزين لتقول
الفصائل ان التمديد بنفس شروط الهدنه
السابقه هنا اعلنت وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا عن امل باريس
باستمرار الهدنه في القطاع حتى يتم
الافراج عن جميع الرهائن وذلك مع افراج
الفصائل عن 58 شخصا خلال الهدنه دون اي
فرنسي بينهم فيما صرح نتنياهو بانه اعرب
للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه بمجرد
انتهائها ستعد العمليات البريه للجيش
بكامل قوتها وافاد التايمز اوف اسرائيل
بان الحكومه بحثت التغييرات في موازنه
2023 رغم التهديدات والاعتراضات المستمره
من عضو حكومه الحرب بين جانس الذي يطالب
بحذف جميع البنود غير المرتبطه بضرورات
الحرب على ذات السياق ذكرت صحيفه دي ع تح
رنوت ان الجيش العبري قرر اقاله ضابطين في
صفوفه بعد معركه شمال القطاع ووفقا
للصحيفه نقلا عن الجيش جاء هذا القرار عقب
تراجع سريه هذين الضابطين في ذروه
المناوره البريه بعد تقدمها دون غطاء ناري
ضد عشرات من الفصائل الذين نصبوا كمينا
للجنود هذا وصرح جز بوريل مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي انه من غير
المجدي تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه لاولئك
الذين سيقتلون غدا لذلك دعا الى اتخاذ
خطوات ملموسه لحل الصراع بين القطاع وتل
ابيب في اليمن كانت مصادر امريكيه قالت
لوكاله رايترز انها مدمره تابعه للقوات
البحريه استجابت لنداء استغاثه من سفينه
سنترال بارك التي تعرضت لهجوم قباله سواحل
اليمن وتمكنت من حمايتها هناك اعلنت
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه ان صاروخين
بالستيين اطلق من اليمن على سفينه يو اس
اس مسن الامريكيه بعد وصولها لانقاذ
الناقله المختطف
بالعوده الى اخبار الاسرى والرهائن كشف
الاعلام العبري ان الصليب الاحمر تسلم 11
رهينه عبريه من القطاع كدفعه رابعه من
الاتفاق كما سيتم الافراج عن سته
تايلنديين خارج الصفقه فيما تم الافراج عن
33 اسيرا لدى الكيان ليكشف مصدر دبلوماسي
لشبكه سي ان ان ان اكثر من 40 عبريا من
الذين احتجزوا في السابع من اكتوبر لا
تحتجزهم الحركه المتفق معها من الفص صائل
وهو ما يعقد الاتفاق اكثر فيما قالت صحيفه
هي ارتس نقلا عن بعض المحتجزين العبريين
المفرج عنهم ان زعيم الفصائل في القطاع
يحيى السنوار قد التقى بعض المحتجزين وذلك
في انفاق القطاع وقال لهم انهم في المكان
الاكثر امانا ولن يحصل لهم مكروه ميدانيا
اعلن الهلال الاحمر دخول 100 شاحنه مساع
الى مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع بموجب الهدنه
فيما اعلن الناطق باسم الدفاع المدني في
القطاع محمود بصل ان اعدادا كبيره من جثث
القتلى لا تزال في محيط مشفي القدس
والرنتيسي في القطاع مطالبا طواقم الدفاع
المدني العربيه بالتدخل من جهه اخرى رجح
نتنياهو خلال حديثه مع رجل الاعمال
الامريكي ايلون ماسك امكانيه مواصله تطبيع
العلاقات مع السعوديه بعد الانتهاء من
الحرب ضد الفصائل في القطاع هناك اعلن
وزير الاتصالات العبريه التوصل الى اتفاق
مع ايلون ماسك الذي وصل الى تل ابيب بان
لا ترنت فضائيه في القطاع في ذات السياق
حطم بريطانيون واجهه مصنع اسلحه يدعم
تلبيب في بريطانيا هذا ما اظهره مقطع
فيديو يحمل هتافات عار عليكم موجه لداعمي
الكيان في حربه على القطاع بعيدا عن حرب
القطاع اعلن البيت الابيض ان الرئيس جو
بايدن سيلجا الى اجراء يعود الى حقبه
الحرب البارده لتعزيز الاستثمار في
التصنيع الامريكي للادويه والامدادات
الطبيه التي اعتبرها مهمه للد فاع الوطني
لمساعده سلاسل التوريد الصناعيه ومواجهه
عده سنوات من التضخم المرتفع في كوريا
الشماليه اكدت بيونجيانج انها ستواصل
ممارسه ما وصفته بحقوقها السياديه ورفضت
الادانات الدوليه بشان اطلاقها قمرا
صناعيا اخيرا كما تعهدت باطلاق المزيد من
الاقمار الصناعيه خلال فتره قصيره بوادر
الانتصار من هنا بدات ملامح النصر وها هو
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يشيد باداء
القطاع المصرفي الروسي في مواجهه العقوبات
وقال ان خصوم روسيا لم يتوقع ان ينجح هذا
القطاع في تجاوز الصعوبات القادمه من
الخارج فيما صرح نائب وزير الصناعه
والتجاره الروسي كير لي سوغر سكي بان
موسكو تمتلك ادله لا تقبل الجدل على ان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها يزودون
اوكرانيا بالمواد الكيميائيه السامه ونا
صرح الامين العام لحلف النيتو ينس سنبر
بان منع التصعيد العسكري مع روسيا هو
المهمه الاساسيه للحلف لعود ستولتنبرج
ويدعو تركيا الى المصادقه على انضمام
السويد الى النيتو في اسرع وقت ممكن قائلا
حان الوقت الان لتنجز تركيا عمليه انضمام
هذا البلد في الميدان الاوكراني افاد ضابط
وكاله المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه
السابق لاري جونسون بان نظام صواريخ
باتريوت المضاد للطائرات الذي قدمته
امريكا سلاح غير فعال في اوكرانيا وخر
مكلفه فيما اشار اعي امريكي الى ان شركاء
اوكرانيا الغربيين يدركون انه من غير
المرجح ان تبقى اوكرانيا صامده حتى العام
المقبل امام روسيا من جانب اخر اشاد تقرير
اعلامي امريكي بالمقاتل الروسيه سوث تي اس
ام التي تقوم بتدمير القوارب المسيره
الاوكرانيه في منطقه العمليه الخاصه ووصف
التقرير الرادار الذي تمتلكه المقاتله
بالفريد وهو احد اكبر الراد على الطائرات
المقاتله في التاريخ يوفر درجه عاليه جدا
من الرؤيه في مختلف
[موسيقى]
الظروف
ا